[Applause] it's played out in front open man
lightning and oh it's kicked out no the referee
said it cross the line I thought it was kept
out on the diving effort by Jacob trouba but
the referee pointed to the goal Patrick
line a shot trickled across the goal line
now the Rangers are guilty of a turnover here
behind the net and as the puck comes back out
in front the the quick shot shesterkin
gets a piece and then trouba with that
effort you see a great for check again a lot of
these plays are off that for check some confusion
in front of churkin he's has a huge push to get
out in front of this puck gets a piece of him now
tro identifies that pucks going towards the goal
line here he goes oh boy what an effort looks like
he just had that stick a little too far inside
the net as I don't know if it gets any closer than
right here oh boy Puck crosses the line it looks
like in total and guess what they're reviewing
it going to have to blow it up here we go oh boy
it's still touching the red there I mean if that's
a s let's keep it rolling a little bit further I
think it's we didn't see I mean that looks like
it's him but that puck is waffling on edge Puck
on edge is trba lunges for it with the stick if
he kept this out it save of the year I'd like to
go back to that blown up video look here's the
overhead I mean there it's still touching
the red Jeff well it is in any part it's
not a goal and here this is the best look I
mean I don't know that that's it to me that's
still on the red line the video review the
puck did not completely cross that's been a
period of reviews here third review third one
gone the other way goals pulled off the board
the Ranger fans in attendance are happy they got
one their way but save of the Year Jacob TR but